gamestop might have confirmed the big
rumor for this year's e3 new consoles
I'm Kate and this is your please don't
call it Xbox to news update speaking
today during game stops latest earnings
briefing coo Tony Bartel said the
retailer is expecting new consoles to be
announced at e3 2016 he didn't say if
they'll come from Microsoft or Sony but
rumors and reports claim that both
companies have new hardware in the works
that could be announced during the show
we expect III to focus on key titles in
the back half of the year and console
announcements he said we also expect VR
to generate significant gaming consumer
and press interest gamestop management
also confirmed today that while it is
expecting new console announcements at
e3 presumably from Microsoft and Sony
the company is not yet modeling any
sales projections into its business
outlook the same is true for Nintendo's
NX which is scheduled to come out in
March 2017 a slide from the company's
briefing included game stops prediction
for NX sales Microsoft is reportedly
working on two new xbox one consoles one
of which is apparently a slimmed-down
model that could be announced at e3
looking further out reports claim
Microsoft is also working on an xbox one
system that is four times as powerful as
the current one Sony meanwhile is
reportedly working on a more powerful
version of the ps4 so au team Xbox to
team ps5 or team and X let me know in
the comments or come and find me on
Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot